Même du ciel,
on les aperçoit.
Au large de la Chine,
dans le nord du pays,
des sillons parfaitement tracés,
en plein océan.
C'est pour ces milliers de petits points
que nous sommes venus jusqu'ici,
dans cette baie
au bout du monde.
À première vue,
on dirait des champs de mines,
mais en fait
ce sont des bouées.
Des bouées à l'infini, sous lesquelles
pousse une plante aux vertus miraculeuses.
Une plante qui est peut-être
un des aliments du futur
pour l'humanité tout entière.
Ce gisement d'or vert,
c'est de l'algue.
Et pour Huang Ming Kwai
que nous accompagnons,
il n'y a rien
de plus simple à cultiver.
- Là, j'attache une petite pierre
au bout de l'algue.
Comme ça, elle ne va pas s'envoler
avec le vent et poussera vers le fond.
- Comme Huang Ming Kwai,
ils sont des milliers de paysans
à récolter l'algue dans cette région.
Car en Asie,
l'algue se mange.
C'est même un aliment de base,
consommé matin, midi et soir
par plus d'un milliard d'individus.
- C'est excellent pour la santé !
- C'est bon ?
- Bien sûr que c'est bon !
- Ça se mange comme ça ?
- Kwai insiste,
l'algue est nourrissante.
En plus autre avantage, la faire pousser,
la cultiver, c'est totalement écologique.
- C'est bon.
- Vous voyez, c'est extra.
Ici, les algues poussent naturellement,
on en récolte des millions de tonnes.
Et pas de soucis,
ça respecte l'environnement.
- Manger de l'algue un jour
chez nous en Europe,
ce n'est pas une plaisanterie.
C'est même une des pistes étudiées
très sérieusement aujourd'hui.
Une nouvelle ressource écologique
et peut-être même l'une des solutions
à un problème qui nous concerne tous.
Celui d'une planète
dont les richesses naturelles s'épuisent
et ne suffisent déjà
plus à nourrir tout le monde.
Toujours plus rapide,
toujours plus moderne,
toujours plus peuplée et surtout,
toujours plus affamée.
Chaque jour, la planète doit nourrir
200 000 nouvelles bouches.
Ce sont 80 millions de personnes
en plus chaque année
qui veulent toutes manger
et manger de tout.
Fruits, légumes,
poissons ou viandes.
L'explosion de la consommation
touche la plupart des pays du globe.
Une mondialisation qui n'est pas
sans conséquence sur notre vie.
Car tout ce que nous produisons
pour manger
a un impact insoupçonné
sur notre environnement.
- Tout ce que vous mangez tous les jours
a plus d'impact sur la planète
que votre maison,
qu'il faut chauffer et éclairer,
ou que vos transports, même quand
vous prenez l'avion, la voiture.
- Voilà ce qui nous a menés
aux quatre coins du monde.
Nous avons voulu comprendre
pourquoi ce que nous mangeons ici
a des répercussions là-bas.
- Si on continue à vouloir toujours
plus d'huile de palme,
un jour la forêt n'existera plus
et nous disparaitrons avec elle.
- Un voyage pour comprendre
comment notre alimentation
s'est industrialisée à outrance.
- On injecte un produit aux bêtes,
des hormones de croissance.
Grâce à cela,
elles grossissent bien plus vite.
- Un voyage pour découvrir
quelles solutions existent déjà
pour s'alimenter tout
en respectant la planète.
- Ce n'est pas un choix économique.
C'est un choix qualitatif.
C'est un choix de donner au consommateur
le meilleur produit possible.
- Un voyage pour explorer
de nouvelles habitudes,
de nouveaux systèmes économiques
imaginés pour préserver la terre
et surtout mieux vivre.
- On ne mange que des aliments
qui viennent du coin,
et ça, c'est meilleur
pour l'environnement.
- Se nourrir, un enjeu vital.
Un enjeu planétaire
qui pousse aujourd'hui certains pays
à chercher toujours
plus loin des terres à cultiver.
- Nous, les Indiens, nous avons récupéré
ces 10 000 hectares ici en Éthiopie,
et nous allons les exploiter
pendant 60 ans.
- Des États-Unis à l'Indonésie,
de la France jusqu'à l'Éthiopie,
nous avons enquêté pour répondre
à une question essentielle,
une question
qui concerne chacun d'entre nous.
Comment est-il possible de tous
se nourrir sans piller la planète ?
Notre voyage commence en France,
en forêt de Fontainebleau,
par une belle journée d'automne.
Ce dimanche midi, Corinne a décidé
de profiter du beau temps
pour aller pique-niquer.
- Allez, en route !
- Et c'est toute une organisation
car Corinne n'est pas seule.
Elle emmène avec elle ses enfants,
ses amis, les enfants de ses amis.
Au total, ils sont une trentaine
à se retrouver
autour de tartes et de salades.
- Vous voulez manger, les enfants ?
- Sans oublier l'ingrédient indispensable
pour un pique-nique réussi, les chips.
- Les chips, pour un pique-nique
c'est obligatoire, on n'a pas le choix.
- Qui les demande ?
Les enfants ou les parents ?
- Les deux.
Il n'y a pas de pique-nique sans chips.
- À chaque fois, les paquets de chips
s'accumulent sur la couverture.
Pas moins
d'une quinzaine ce jour-là.
Des arômes différents
et un ingrédient un peu mystérieux.
Il est indiqué au dos du paquet.
Cet ingrédient s'appelle l'huile de palme
et il est très utilisé.
C'est ce que nous avons constaté
en démarrant notre enquête.
Au rayon chips, plus d'un paquet sur deux
contient de l'huile de palme.
Une huile qui laisse
le consommateur perplexe.
- Vous connaissez l'huile de palme ?
- Non, pas du tout.
- L'huile de palme ?
- C'est une plante, non ?
À vrai dire, je ne sais pas.
- C'est une huile
qui vient d'une céréale ?
- Je n'en ai jamais dégusté.
- Pourtant l'huile de palme,
nous en consommons tous les jours
sans vraiment le savoir, car aujourd'hui
elle est dans presque tous les rayons.
Pour s'en rendre compte,
nous avons fait nos courses.
Pour le petit déjeuner,
des brioches aux pépites de chocolat.
Pour déjeuner
sur le pouce, un croque-monsieur,
une tarte salée ou un plat cuisiné,
des biscuits apéritifs
et pour le dîner,
des pâtes fraîches.
Tous ces produits
contiennent de l'huile de palme.
Aussi dans les pâtes feuilletées,
les sauces, les pâtes à tartiner,
les confiseries,
les biscuits, les soupes,
les glaces, les céréales, le pain grillé.
Une huile de palme que l'on retrouve
même dans du lait pour bébé.
Alors nous avons voulu en savoir plus
sur cette huile
qui se répand dans nos aliments.
Vous allez le voir,
derrière ce simple ingrédient,
se cache toute une histoire.
Une histoire qui mêle intérêts économiques
et enjeux écologiques majeurs.
Nous partons pour Aubagne, en Provence.
Pourquoi cette ville est-elle devenue
le chouchou des industriels ?
Un élément de réponse se trouve ici.
La société Sibell est spécialisée
dans la fabrication de chips.
Trois lignes de production,
des pommes de terre pelées,
découpées, cuites,
salées à longueur de journée.
Ici la fabrication des chips
n'a rien d'artisanale.
- Ça fait combien
de tonnes par an de chips ?
- 8 000 tonnes environ par an de chips.
- Dans ces 8 000 tonnes,
il y a les chips que Gilles Benkemoun
fabrique sous sa propre marque, Sibell.
Il utilise alors de l'huile de tournesol
pour frire les pétales de pommes de terre.
Mais Gilles travaille surtout
pour les marques distributeurs.
Casino, Intermarché,
Système U ou encore Netto.
Ces clients représentent
70 % de sa production.
Souvent il lui demande la même chose :
produire moins cher.
Alors Gilles n'a pas le choix.
Il remplace l'huile de tournesol
par de l'huile de palme.
- Cette cuve, c'est l'huile de palme,
injectée par les tuyaux dans la friteuse.
- Quel est l'intérêt
de l'huile de palme pour faire des chips ?
- Le prix.
- L'huile de palme
est bien moins cher ?
- Oui.
- Une huile imbattable,
environ 15 % moins cher
que toutes les autres.
Et cette huile miracle
qui permet de fabriquer moins cher,
voici à quoi elle ressemble.
Dans son laboratoire, Gilles Benkemoun
en garde quelques échantillons.
- On a plus l'impression
que c'est du sirop ça, presque.
- On dirait du sirop.
- L'huile de palme,
les industriels de l'alimentaire
l'utilisent de plus en plus.
C'est même aujourd'hui la matière grasse
la plus employée au monde.
Le problème, c'est que
la plupart des entreprises
s'approvisionnent au même endroit.
Conséquence, cette production d'huile
bouleverse l'environnement
et la vie de populations entières
à l'autre bout de la planète.
Pour le comprendre,
nous partons à des milliers de kilomètres.
En Indonésie, à Bornéo.
Une île grande comme une fois
et demie la France.
Accrochée au fleuve Kayan,
la ville de Palangkaraya.
C'est ici que commence
notre périple sur l'île de Bornéo.
Le cœur de l'industrie de l'huile de palme
se trouve à 6 h de route.
Cap au sud, à travers
la campagne indonésienne,
pour arriver aux portes d'une entreprise.
A l'entrée sur la pancarte,
un W pour Wilmar,
un géant de l'huile de palme,
le plus gros producteur
de toute l'Asie du sud-est.
Et voici ce que gardent
ces hommes en uniforme.
Dans l'ocre de la piste,
de chaque côté, un seul arbre.
Toujours le même.
Le palmier à huile.
Des centaines.
Des milliers.
Des millions.
En fait, un territoire entier
redessiné par l'homme.
Des hectares et des hectares
couverts de palmiers à huile.
Une culture intensive et massive
qui a changé la géographie
et l'environnement
de cette région du monde.
Aujourd'hui, l'Indonésie et son voisin,
la Malaisie fabriquent 80 %
de l'huile de palme mondiale.
Et pour assurer la production,
une armée d'ouvriers
est sur le pied de guerre,
365 jours par an.
Ce matin-là,
nous avons rendez-vous à 6 h
au cœur de la plantation Wilmar.
La journée commence toujours
par le même cérémonial.
Les managers en blanc
rappellent les consignes aux ouvriers.
- Les quinze qui étaient hier
sur la parcelle 128 de la zone S12,
vous continuez au même endroit.
Domingo et Pram, vous,
vous restez sur la zone PH.
Vous, Tumera,
faites attention de planter les palmiers
comme il faut et pas n'importe comment.
Il en reste encore 400.
Essayez d'en planter
au moins 250 aujourd'hui.
- Ici, chaque ouvrier couvre à lui seul
sept hectares de plantation chaque jour
et la cadence doit être respectée.
- Vous leur demandez toujours
de produire plus ?
- L'objectif
qu'ils doivent atteindre,
c'est de ramasser les fruits de deux
ou trois rangées de palmiers par jour.
Souvent ils y arrivent mais je le répète
pour que la production ne baisse pas.
Si je ne le dis pas,
certains travaillent moins bien.
- C'est une façon
de leur mettre la pression.
- Voilà, c'est ça.
- Si les managers mettent autant
la pression sur leurs ouvriers,
c'est parce que ce qui se récolte
ici a une immense valeur.
Ce fruit rouge qui pousse
en grosses grappes,
à quelques mètres du sol.
Voilà d'où vient l'huile de palme.
Et c'est cela que des employés comme
Toma Rau viennent chaque jour cueillir.
Toma Rau a 27 ans.
Il est venu de Java, l'île voisine,
pour trouver du travail.
Toute la journée,
avec sa longue perche,
il traque les meilleurs fruits.
Vous pouvez m'expliquer
ce qu'il y a là ?
- Vous voyez, ce fruit
est bien rouge à l'extérieur
et très orange à l'intérieur.
Ça veut dire qu'il est mûr.
Il y a plein d'huile dedans.
- Oui, c'est huileux,
c'est gras, c'est ça ?
- Exactement.
- Pour être bien sûr que Thomas Rau
ne ramasse que les fruits les plus mûrs,
Wilmar a trouvé la solution.
L'entreprise le paie
pour partie en fonction
des fruits qu'il récolte.
Plus ils sont gorgés d'huile,
plus Thomas regagne de l'argent.
En moyenne, 2 € par jour
pour livrer sur le bord du chemin
sa production quotidienne de fruits.
Des fruits qui sont immédiatement
collectés par une armada de camions,
qui sillonnent sans cesse la plantation.
Car pour répondre
à une demande en pleine explosion,
et tenir les cadences,
la société a tout prévu.
L'huile est fabriquée directement
sur place dans ce pressoir.
Une usine qui tourne jour et nuit
dans un vacarme assourdissant.
Les fruits récoltés
y sont immédiatement déversés.
Ils sont bouillis
dans ces grandes citernes, écrasés,
filtrés pour finalement devenir
ce liquide sombre
à l'odeur pestilentielle.
Mais ça, Harry, le manager de l'usine,
n'en a pas grand-chose à faire.
Lui, il n'a qu'un seul objectif,
augmenter la production d'huile.
En deux ans,
il l'a presque doublée.
Elle atteindra bientôt 100 000 tonnes
et ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter.
- Ça, c'est l'huile de palme
que nous en Europe, on va consommer ?
- Oui, d'abord on la raffine
et puis on l'envoie chez vous.
Il y en a partout
dans votre supermarché,
dans les gâteaux, les biscuits,
dans les poissons pané, vraiment partout.
- C'est une cash machine,
cette huile pour vous ?
- Bien sûr,
elle ne coûte pas cher à produire.
Le rendement est chez nous est excellent.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec l'huile de soja.
Imaginez qu'un hectare de palmier donne
dix fois plus d'huile qu'un de soja.
Donc l'huile de palme est moins chère.
- Ici, en Indonésie,
cette huile de palme si abondante,
est considérée
comme un cadeau du ciel.
Un cadeau en réalité tout
ce qu'il y a de plus terrestre.
Une culture, lancée par un Français
il y a presque un siècle.
En 1905, Henri Fauconnier arrive en Asie.
Un pionnier, écrivain,
un peu touche à tout,
qui veut d'abord
cultiver le caoutchouc.
Puis il a l'idée, avec un ami,
d'importer du Congo,
quelques graines de palmier à huile.
Un arbre qui pousse-là bas,
avec une facilité étonnante.
En 1912, il fonde en Malaisie
la première exploitation commerciale
de palmiers à huile,
puis acquiert
des terres en Indonésie.
Le succès de cette culture
ne se démentira pas.
Un siècle plus tard,
cette région du monde produit chaque année
40 millions de tonnes d'huile de palme
et la demande ne cesse d'augmenter.
Alors des entreprises comme Wilmar
étendent encore leurs plantations.
Une expansion menée tambour battant
au prix d'un incroyable
bouleversement écologique.
Car pour faire de la place
aux palmiers à huile,
il a fallu tailler dans le vert.
Des tronçonneuses
qui abattent des arbres,
les uns après les autres
avec des machines
ou lors d'incendies volontaires,
la forêt vierge est ravagée.
Un rythme effrayant.
Ici, à Bornéo, 2 millions d'hectares
disparaissent chaque année.
Et sur cette île,
voici ce qu'il s'est passé en 60 ans.
En 1950, la forêt vierge est partout.
Au fil des années,
elle disparaît irrémédiablement.
Et dans 10 ans, si rien n'est fait,
voici ce qu'il en restera.
Une déforestation massive qui est visible
partout lorsque nous parcourons le pays.
Une déforestation qui fait polémique
car la forêt vierge
est essentielle pour notre vie.
Pour le comprendre,
nous nous rendons
dans l'un des derniers
espaces préservés de ces plantations.
De la forêt primaire,
conservée par la société Wilmar,
sous la pression de l'opinion.
Pour nous guider
dans ce dédale vert,
nous rencontrons Kelly,
une biologiste qui vient du Zimbabwe.
Elle a été embauchée par Wilmar
pour protéger ses forêts.
Une cathédrale de feuillage
où résonnent des bruits étranges.
En quoi est-ce important de garder
la forêt pour les êtres humain ?
- Nous avons besoin de la forêt vierge
pour notre propre santé, notre futur.
C'est le poumon du monde.
- C'est-à-dire ?
- Cette forêt est importante pour nous.
Par exemple, à Paris, vous polluez,
les voitures rejettent du gaz carbonique.
Ici, à l'autre bout de la planète,
ces arbres capturent ces gaz
et à la place,
ils rejettent de l'oxygène.
- Pas le gaz
de nos voitures à Paris ?
- Non, en fait, c'est une image.
Pensez à l'échelle mondiale.
La forêt produit de l'oxygène.
Si vous rasez la forêt, vous relâchez tout
le gaz carbonique dans l'air.
Et ça, ça augmente
le réchauffement climatique
et ça change
le climat de la planète.
- C'est bien ça le plus préoccupant.
Moins de forêts, ça veut dire
moins d'arbres pour capturer le CO2.
Or, replanter des palmiers ne suffit pas
car ce sont des plantes
et non pas des arbres.
Ils absorbent trois fois
moins de gaz carbonique
que la forêt vierge.
Et le CO2 est l'un des gaz
à effet de serre
qui accélère
le réchauffement climatique.
Lorsque les rayons du soleil
atteignent la planète,
une partie d'entre
eux est réfléchie vers le ciel.
Le problème, c'est que le CO2 accumulé
dans l'atmosphère
bloque une partie de ces rayons solaires
et les renvois vers le sol.
C'est l'une des causes
de l'augmentation de la température
et donc du réchauffement climatique.
L'Indonésie
a sa part de responsabilité.
Ce pays est devenu l'un
des principaux producteurs mondiaux
de gaz à effet de serre, en grande partie
à cause de cette déforestation massive.
Ces arbres si importants
pour l'avenir de la planète,
renferment aussi
des richesses insoupçonnées.
Des espèces rares.
Grandes ou minuscules.
- C'est typique de la forêt vierge ?
- Oui, c'est caractéristique de voir
beaucoup de fourmis ou ces termites.
Il y a une très grande biodiversité ici.
Celles-ci mangent le bois,
les arbres mort tombés par terre.
Vous savez, la forêt,
c'est un écosystème.
Tout est lié.
Il y a des espèces clés dans la forêt.
Si vous retirez l'une d'elles,
tout peut s'écrouler.
- Oui, c'est évidemment essentiel
pour notre vie.
- Le problème, c'est que cette nature
dont parle Kelly est aujourd'hui menacée.
Menacée par la production massive
d'huile de palme,
que l'on utilise
pour fabriquer des chips,
comme des centaines
d'autres produits alimentaires.
Car lorsque la forêt primaire
est remplacée par des palmiers,
des milliers d'espèces vivantes
disparaissent peu à peu.
À commencer par l'une des plus visibles,
l'orang-outan.
Il y en avait 10 000,
il y a cinq ans.
Il y en a moitié moins aujourd'hui.
Ces singes sont souvent tués
lorsque les arbres sont coupés.
Ceux qui en réchappent
errent parmi les palmiers à huile
et meurent de faim.
Mais lors de notre voyage,
nous avons découvert un autre phénomène
dont nous n'avions pas imaginé l'ampleur.
Aujourd'hui, vous allez le voir,
l'huile de palme ne met plus seulement
en péril les animaux.
Pour le comprendre,
nous allons nous enfoncer
à l'intérieur d'un autre monde.
Aujourd'hui, vous allez le voir,
l'huile de palme ne met plus seulement
en péril les animaux.
Pour le comprendre,
nous allons nous enfoncer
à l'intérieur d'un autre monde.
Une journée de routes
et de pistes cabossées.
Des heures de marche,
sac au dos,
dans ce qui s'appelle ici
les douze collines.
Nous arrivons enfin dans un
des derniers espaces de forêts vierges.
Habitée par les Orang Rimba,
les hommes de la forêt.
Tumangon est le chef de la tribu.
Avec sa femme et ses 17 enfants,
ils habitent ces abris sommaires
qu'ils bâtissent où ils veulent.
Ils sont nomades
depuis des générations.
Ils vivent en harmonie totale
avec la nature.
- Pour les nourrissons,
on utilise ces feuilles de samoune.
Ça les protège, on les a emmaillote dedans
et ils sont sains et saufs.
- Il y a 64 familles ici,
dans un espace de vie
qui se réduit sans cesse
à cause de la déforestation
et c'est toute leur existence
qui est en jeu.
Car moins de forêts,
cela signifie moins de nourriture.
Les Orang Rimba vivent
de la pêche et de la chasse.
Actuellement, la viande
devient de plus en plus rare.
- C'est de plus en plus difficile pour moi
de trouver à manger pour ma famille.
Avant, la forêt était plus grande.
C'était plus facile
pour nous de chasser.
Il y avait plus d'animaux.
Maintenant que la forêt rétrécit,
c'est plus dur.
- Pour ce cochon sauvage,
par exemple,
il a fallu chasser plusieurs jours
au fin fond de la forêt.
Alors qu'auparavant, quelques heures
aux alentours suffisaient.
Désormais pour subsister,
les Orangs Rimba
vendent aux hommes de la ville,
ces fruits rouges utilisés
pour colorer les tissus.
Ou ce bois, qui sert à fabriquer
des chaises ou des tables.
Mais aujourd'hui, Tumangon,
ne sait pas si ces enfants pourront vivre
comme lui a vécu, en hommes des forêts.
- On est en danger.
L'huile de palme est
une menace pour nous.
Si les plantations de palmiers
continuent à grossir, un jour,
la forêt n'existera plus
et nous non plus.
C'en sera fini des Orangs Rimba.
- Une menace chantée le soir venu
par les sages de la tribu.
Ils évoquent leur forêt d'autrefois,
large et généreuse,
désormais, un vieux souvenir.
Les Orang Rimba parviendront-ils
à préserver leur forêt ?
Pour cela, il faudrait
que la demande en huile de palme diminue.
C'est l'Europe
qui en importe le plus.
Et dans nos médias, l'huile de palme
commence à être pointée du doigt.
Pour des raisons environnementales,
mais pas uniquement.
L'huile de palme serait également mauvaise
pour notre santé.
Elle contient quatre fois plus
de mauvaises graisses
que l'huile de tournesol ou de colza.
Pour ces raisons,
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux
à vouloir diminuer notre consommation.
Mais encore faut-il savoir
dans quel produit elle se trouve.
Car en ce moment, certains industriels
jouent sur l'ambiguïté.
De retour en France,
nous avons acheté plusieurs produits.
Rien n'indique
qu'ils contiennent de l'huile de palme.
Sur leurs emballages,
dans la liste des ingrédients,
Il n'y a souvent que ces mots :
matière grasse végétale
ou bien huile végétale.
Pourtant, voilà ce qu'on nous répond quand
on appelle les services consommateurs.
- Service consommateurs, bonjour.
À tous, nous leur avons posé
la même question.
- J'ai vu qu'il y avait marqué
huile végétale.
Je voulais savoir
ce que c'était exactement.
- C'est de l'huile de palme.
- Pour la matière végétale,
c'est de l'huile de palme.
- C'est de quel végétal
cette matière grasse végétale ?
- L'huile de palme.
- C'est l'huile de palme.
- Tout à fait.
- Huile de palme.
- Essentiellement,
on utilise de l'huile de palme.
- Une huile présente
dans tous nos produits,
mais passées sous silence,
c'est tout à fait légal.
La réglementation n'oblige pas
les industriels
à le spécifier sur les paquets.
Ce qui les arrange,
car cette huile de palme
devient de moins en moins populaire
auprès des consommateurs.
Certains tentent de faire pression
sur les industriels de l'alimentaire.
C'est ce qui est arrivé
à l'entreprise anglaise Cadbury.
Leur chocolat Dairy Milk,
à l'huile de palme,
a été boycotté par les consommateurs
en Nouvelle-Zélande.
- J'ai toujours acheté
du chocolat Cadbury
mais depuis qu'ils utilisent de l'huile
de palme, j'ai changé de marque.
- Du coup, l'entreprise s'est excusée
et a fait machine arrière.
Elle a retiré l'huile de palme
des chocolats vendus en Nouvelle-Zélande.
Mais alors nous, en France,
pouvons-nous également
acheter des produits
sans huile de palme ?
Notre enquête nous conduit
dans le nord de la France,
à Boulogne-sur-Mer,
siège d'une marque vieille de 60 ans
très connue des Français,
l'entreprise Findus.
Le best-seller ici,
c'est le poisson pané.
17 000 tonnes produites l'année dernière.
Ça ne se voit pas comme ça,
mais cette usine a été le théâtre
d'une petite révolution,
conduite par Matthieu Lambeaux, le PDG.
Il a décidé de changer d'huile
pour cuire ses poissons.
Il a remplacé l'huile de palme
par de l'huile de colza.
Elle demande
beaucoup plus d'attention
car il faut la changer plus souvent
et surtout, la surveiller
toutes les heures.
- Elle est plus difficile à manier,
plus instable.
- C'est plus compliqué pour vous ?
- Oui, c'est plus compliqué.
- Ça vous coûte plus cher.
- Ça coûte plus cher,
mais choisir l'huile de colza,
par définition, ce n'est pas un choix
économique mais un choix qualitatif.
Pour donner au consommateur
le meilleur produit possible.
Il se trouve que malheureusement,
en général, ce sont des choses
qui coûtent plus cher.
Pour Matthieu Lambeaux,
l'huile de colza est un surcoût
de 3 millions d'euros.
Entièrement à sa charge,
puisqu'il n'augmentera pas le prix
de ses produits dans les supermarchés.
Mais ce qu'il espère,
c'est rentabiliser son investissement
en augmentant ses ventes.
Pour cela, il doit d'abord s'assurer
que changer d'huile ne change pas le goût.
Dans les bureaux de l'entreprise,
il y a une cuisine expérimentale.
Ce jour-là,
une épreuve se prépare.
Elle est dirigée par Steven Libermann,
responsable marketing.
- On est là pour valider
le dernier produit
à passer en huile de colza,
les Crousti Express Quartiers.
- Le produit, le voici,
tout juste sorti du micro-onde.
Ce sont des pommes de terre.
- Donc là on est en l'huile de colza
et là, c'est palme et colza.
Ok. Allez-y.
- Ce qui est important, c'est de juger,
si vous voyez une différence de goût,
si c'est moins gras.
si le produit
est toujours aussi croustillant.
- Je ne vois pas de différence
entre les deux.
- Même constat
pour Steven et son équipe.
Reste maintenant à transformer
l'opération en machine à vendre.
Pour cela, l'argument est bien mis
en évidence sur le paquet.
C'est fabriqué avec de l'huile de colza,
et non de l'huile de palme.
- En fait, c'est indiqué ici.
- Mais on ne le fait pas
simplement pour avoir une belle image.
- Non, c'est une question d'éthique.
- Pas seulement.
C'est aussi car on a le sentiment que
le consommateur va se tourner vers vous.
- Oui, on ambitionne une croissance
de 15 % sur les trois ans.
Effectivement.
Voilà pourquoi vendre des produits écolos
peut servir des intérêts financiers.
L'entreprise a ainsi déjà vu progresser
ses ventes de 8 % l'année dernière.
Le citoyen, le consommateur
a donc le pouvoir
de faire changer
les méthodes des industriels.
En faisant attention à ce qu'il achète,
il peut inciter les entreprises
de l'agroalimentaire
à davantage respecter l'environnement.
L'enjeu est de taille,
car actuellement,
80 % de ce que nous mangeons
est produit industriellement.
Et la tendance va encore s'amplifier.
Nous serons 7 milliards d'humains en 2012
à vouloir manger plus,
mais surtout manger la même chose.
Du poulet en nuggets,
des saucisses industrielles
ou des yaourt aux fruits.
Mais l'aliment qui depuis quelques années
est devenu la star
des assiettes du monde entier :
c'est le bœuf.
- Oui alors,
moi je ne mange que ça.
Vous avez vu ?
Pas mal.
- En 50 ans, Européens et Américains
ont doublé leur consommation de viande.
Rien qu'en France, nous avalons
350 grammes de bœuf par semaine.
Mais aujourd'hui,
nous ne sommes plus les seuls
à vouloir manger de la viande.
Désormais, tout le monde veut son steak.
Russes, Chinois,
Pakistanais, Indiens ou Brésiliens.
Sur tous les continents,
le bœuf est en train de devenir l'aliment
préféré des classes moyennes.
Le symbole
de la réussite économique.
Dans 40 ans,
la consommation mondiale aura doublé.
Or, vous allez découvrir
que produire en masse de la viande de bœuf
est l'une des activités
les plus polluantes pour notre planète.
Pour s'en rendre compte, nous partons
dans la patrie historique du bœuf,
aux États-Unis.
A 8 000 kilomètres de Paris, le Texas.
Dans les grandes plaines,
impossible de rater l'animal.
Il vous fait saliver jusque
sur les camions,
qui défilent sur l'autoroute.
Ici les habitants consomment
40 kilos de bœuf par personne et par an,
quatre fois plus
que la moyenne mondiale.
Steakhouse ou fast food.
Partout, le bœuf est roi.
C'est ici que se trouvent
les plus grands élevages du monde.
Sous nos yeux, 75 000 bêtes.
On appelle ça des feed-lots,
des parcs d'engraissement.
Il s'agit plutôt d'usines
à faire grossir les vaches,
un système qui défie
toutes les lois de la nature.
Ça commence dès l'arrivée du bétail.
Chaque matin, c'est le même rituel
pour Larry, le manager.
Il accueille de nouvelles cargaisons,
des quatre coins des États-Unis.
- Vous en recevez beaucoup ?
- Ça dépend,
2 500 par semaine à peu près.
- Le programme qui les attend, six mois
d'un régime intensif avant l'abattoir.
Dès l'arrivée,
elles passent sur la balance.
- Ce lot pèse 47 000 livres,
ça fait 21 tonnes.
- C'est beaucoup ou pas ?
- On a chargé
le camion au maximum.
Il est plein à craquer.
- Elles vont grossir beaucoup ?
- Quand elles partiront,
il faudra deux camions
au lieu d'un seul.
- À la tête de ce parc,
un cow boy pur jus.
Un cow-boy qui a troqué
son cheval contre un hélicoptère.
Paul Engler a 80 ans, une réussite
incontestée dans la profession.
Il possède dix parcs d'engraissement
aux États-Unis.
Dans les bureaux de Cactus
Feeders, son entreprise,
les employés le voient rarement plus
d'une fois par semaine.
[English spoken audio]
500 employés travaillent pour Paul
sur ses différents sites.
Le patron n'a plus grand chose à faire,
sinon se réjouir de l'augmentation
de son cours de bourse.
- En 1990, la compagnie
était valorisée à 40 $ l'action.
Vous voyez, on a fait beaucoup de profits
et maintenant on est à 328 $ par action.
On est vraiment très fiers.
- Fils d'éleveur traditionnel,
Paul Engler s'est lancé
dans le business il y a 50 ans.
À l'époque, il était l'un des premiers
à opter pour l'élevage intensif.
Jusqu'aux années 1940,
avant de partir à l'abattoir,
les vaches ne mangeaient
que de l'herbe, dans de grands espaces.
Mais après la guerre, tout a changé.
La demande de viande explose,
c'est la période des 30 glorieuses.
Fast food à tous les coins de rue
et hamburgers pour tous,
le bœuf se démocratise.
Pour répondre à cette demande,
les éleveurs comme Paul
vont inventer un nouveau mode d'élevage,
industrialisé à outrance.
Aujourd'hui, Paul Engler doit produire
plus de 7 000 tonnes de steak par semaine.
Pour y arriver, il doit faire grossir
ses bêtes en un temps record.
Alors il a mis au point
un traitement de choc,
qui rentabilise
son bétail au maximum.
Un traitement
où la nature cède le pas à la science.
D'abord dès l'arrivée dans l'exploitation,
séance de piqûres
à la chaîne pour les vaches.
Un vaccin contre les parasites.
Mais surtout une injection
à base d'hormones de croissance.
- Voici les doses
qu'on injecte aux bêtes.
Ce sont essentiellement
des hormones de croissance.
Grâce à ces piqûres,
les vaches grossissent plus vite.
Du coup, on a besoin
de moins de nourriture
pour produire
un kilo de viande de bœuf.
- Moins de nourriture, certes,
mais une nourriture ultra dopantes.
Car ici, les vaches suivent un régime
qui les transforme
en d'incroyables machines à viande.
Dans le feed-lot,
elles n'ont pas d'herbe à brouter.
Leur repas est entièrement
fabriqué à l'usine.
L'ingrédient principal arrive par camion.
Des tonnes de maïs,
stockées pour le bétail.
Or, par nature,
les vaches ne mangent pas de céréales.
Qu'importe, le nutritionniste
n'a pas d'état d'âme.
Les animaux vont devoir s'y faire.
- On nourrit les bêtes au maïs
parce que le maïs leur
fait prendre du poids beaucoup plus vite.
Évidemment, avec leur estomac
habitué à l'herbe,
il faut les adapter
à ce nouveau régime.
Alors au début, on leur donne
un mélange d'herbe et de maïs.
Puis ensuite, on passe
entièrement au maïs.
- Mais il y a encore mieux
pour engraisser une vache.
Dans ces machines, le maïs est transformé
en un aliment hyper calorique.
Un aliment que nous connaissons tous
au petit déjeuner,
le corn flakes.
- En transformant
le maïs en corn flakes,
on augmente encore
la prise de poids de 10 à 12 %.
- Les vaches sont ainsi gavées
par camions jour et nuit.
Un régime qui leur fait prendre
plus d'un kilo par jour.
Résultat, chaque bête est prête
pour l'abattoir
en seulement 18 mois
au lieu de trois ans d'ordinaire.
Voilà pourquoi ce système de production
s'est exporté dans de nombreux pays.
En Australie, en Argentine ou au Brésil.
En France, le recours
aux hormones de croissance
est interdit dans les élevages.
En revanche, plus de la moitié des vaches
qui finissent dans nos assiettes
a été nourries avec des céréales,
de manière industrielle.
Grâce à ces méthodes,
dans les supermarchés du monde entier,
le prix de la viande a ainsi baissé
de plus de 30 % en 30 ans.
Mais fournir un steak toujours moins cher,
à toujours plus de monde,
a un coût écologique gigantesque.
Car les élevages de masse
sont extrêmement polluants.
D'abord à cause
de ce qu'ingurgite le bœuf,
plus d'une tonne de céréales
avant d'aller à l'abattoir.
Or, pour produire ces céréales,
il a fallu parfois
raser des forêts entières.
Asperger des champs de pesticides,
puis acheminer le maïs
avec des milliers de camions
qui rejettent
du dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Une grande part de la pollution
provient de la vache elle-même.
Lorsqu'elle rumine et digère ses aliments,
la vache rejette un gaz très polluant,
le méthane.
Ce gaz est l'un
des plus nocifs pour la planète.
Au total, selon l'organisation mondiale
de l'agriculture, la FAO,
les élevages industriels,
surtout de bœuf,
sont responsables de 18 % des gaz à effet
de serre émis dans le monde.
C'est plus que toutes les voitures
qui roulent sur la planète.
L'élevage industriel
de bœuf pollue donc l'air.
Mais il pollue aussi les sols et cela met
directement en danger notre santé.
Au départ, cela peut prêter à sourire.
Mais pour Larry, le manager du feed-lot,
c'est un vrai problème.
75 000 bêtes
concentrées sur une surface réduite,
ça laisse des traces.
- On est envahi par la bouse,
Vous n'imaginez pas,
mais chaque animal produit environ
une tonne pendant son séjour ici.
Une tonne.
- Tout ça ici, ça fait combien ?
- Rien que dans cet enclos,
ça fait à peu près
200 tonnes de bouse sur l'année.
- Une vache produit 20 fois
plus d'excréments qu'un être humain.
Ici, ces déjections
sont déblayés régulièrement.
Mais lorsque ce n'est pas le cas,
elles peuvent infiltrer le sol.
Les bouses risquent alors
d'atteindre la nappe phréatique
et la contaminer
avec des hormones de croissance,
des antibiotiques
que l'on a donné aux animaux.
Mais aussi des nitrates
contenus dans les déjections.
Or, la nappe phréatique
alimente la population en eau.
Cette pollution peut avoir
des conséquences dramatiques sur la santé.
Des dizaines de milliers d'Américains
sont confrontés à ce problème.
Pour le comprendre,
nous avons mené l'enquête
tout autour de ces élevages intensifs.
Direction l'État de l'Idaho,
dans le Nord-Ouest des États-Unis.
Une région très rurale,
où les vaches sont deux fois
plus nombreuses que les habitants.
Ici comme ailleurs dans le pays,
les élevages ont des effets
dévastateurs sur la santé.
Alors, face à cette menace,
une femme a décidé de briser le silence.
Elle s'appelle Alma Hasse.
Alma s'est installée
dans la région pour la nature.
Mais quand cette cheffe d'entreprise
a emménagé en 2005,
elle a découvert
qu'elle était entourée de feed-lots.
- S'il n'y avait pas de feed-lots,
ce serait le paradis ici,
on serait vraiment heureux.
Très vite, avec sa fille,
Alma a décidé de se mobiliser.
Dans le voisinage,
les langues ont commencé à se délier.
Dans ses cartons,
des dizaines de témoignages accablants.
À chaque fois,
face aux géants de l'industrie du bœuf,
les familles semblent
complètement démunies.
- Les élevages s'installent souvent
dans des zones rurales pauvres.
C'est tout bénef,
car les habitants n'ont pas l'argent
pour se défendre et se payer un avocat.
Et d'une certaine façon,
ils misent là-dessus.
En ce moment,
l'affaire qui occupe tout son temps
est un véritable scandale sanitaire.
Une histoire qui met en cause
les pouvoirs publics.
Nous nous rendons
vers le nord de l'Idaho,
à Sunny Side.
En seulement sept ans,
cette petite localité a été décimée.
10 % des habitants sont morts d'un cancer.
Un taux 10 fois supérieur
à la moyenne nationale.
Pour la population, il y a un coupable
en plein milieu du village,
cet élevage de bœuf.
Parmi les survivants de cette hécatombe,
les Wandrey.
- Bonjour,
merci de nous recevoir.
- Bonjour, je ne suis pas
très présentable.
- Ça va, vous êtes parfait !
Pearl et Jim Wandrey,
aujourd'hui retraités,
habitent cette maison depuis 1990.
Ils travaillaient
dans leur station-service,
quand ils ont vu s'installer
en bordure de leur propriété, 4000 vaches.
C'était il y a dix ans.
Aujourd'hui, l'exploitation est fermée,
mais elle a laissé des traces.
Voici ce que les Wandrey
voyaient depuis chez eux.
Ces images amateurs ont été filmées
à l'époque par un autre voisin.
Les animaux vivaient
dans des conditions déplorables.
Par temps de pluie,
les bêtes pataugeaient jusqu'à la panse
dans un mélange de boue et d'excréments.
La bouse n'était jamais évacuée.
Résultat, elle s'infiltrait
dans la nappe phréatique.
- Votre eau, elle était comment ?
- Noire, on ne pouvait pas se doucher
Pour faire la vaisselle,
c'était vraiment dégoûtant.
- Le comble,
c'est que l'état de l'Idaho le savait.
Les habitants
en ont aujourd'hui la preuve.
Dans ce rapport,
les autorités reconnaissent
avoir fait dès 2004
des tests sur l'eau des habitants.
Nitrates, hormones de croissance,
antibiotiques,
tous ces produits
ont été détectés.
Il est même écrit que cela présente
un risque pour la santé des résidents.
Pourtant, les riverains qui demandaient
la fermeture de l'exploitation
n'ont jamais été écoutés
par les autorités.
- Ils nous redirigeaient.
L'agriculture disait qu'il fallait
s'adresser à l'environnement.
L'environnement disait
qu'il fallait s'adresser à l'agriculture.
Ils nous ont baladés pendant des années.
- L'État ne demandera
jamais de comptes à l'éleveur,
qui partira finalement de lui-même
car son élevage n'était plus rentable.
Mais le problème, c'est que la bouse,
elle, est toujours là.
24 000 tonnes séchées, accumulées
dans ses anciens enclos,
qui trois ans après,
continuent à polluer.
Mais alors pourquoi l'État
a-t-il laissé faire ?
C'est ce que nous avons voulu savoir.
Malgré toutes nos demandes,
les autorités ont refusé
de nous accorder une interview.
A Boise, capitale de l'Idaho,
nous décidons alors d'accompagner Alma
au département de l'agriculture.
Nous filmons l'entretien
en caméra cachée.
- Bonjour.
- Bonjour Madame la directrice.
Je suis Alma Hasse et voici Guy Lagache.
- Bonjour Madame.
- Mais une fois de plus, Alma
ne va pas trouver une oreille attentive.
[English spoken audio]
- L'ancien feed-lot continue à polluer.
C'est un vrai problème.
Ces personnes souffrent toujours,
tous les jours.
On ne sait pas quelles seront
les conséquences pour eux à long terme.
Personne de votre département n'a jamais
cherché à s'informer auprès des riverains.
Il y a des cancers, des leucémies,
de vrais problèmes de santé publique
et tout le monde continue à s'en moquer.
Ce n'est pas juste.
- Attendez une minute,
je vais chercher Brian.
- La question d'Alma reste sans réponse.
La directrice appelle son adjoint à l'aide
et, surprise,
celui-ci écourte le rendez-vous.
- Je crois que le mieux pour vous,
c'est de partir.
- Vous protégez qui ?
Les citoyens ou les éleveurs ?
- Ecoutez, revenez plus tard,
vous serez les bienvenus.
D'ici là, ne poussez pas trop loin.
- Il s'intéresse juste à l'environnement,
comme moi.
- Ok, j'en suis ravi.
Mais la directrice est très occupée,
elle n'a pas de temps à perdre,
surtout avec un touriste
qui vient pour nous critiquer.
- Quand on parle du bœuf
aux officiels de l'État,
nous sommes face à un mur.
Selon Alma,
la raison est extrêmement simple.
- Le problème, c'est que le département
de l'agriculture a deux casquettes.
Son rôle, c'est à la fois
de promouvoir l'industrie du bœuf
et c'est aussi
de réguler les élevages
et donc de préserver
l'intérêt des citoyens.
Il y a conflit d'intérêt.
Comment pouvez-vous
défendre correctement l'industrie
et en même temps
faire respecter les règles ?
C'est impossible.
- Avec ce type de fonctionnement,
l'élevage intensif n'est donc
pas prêt d'être remis en cause.
Pourtant, aujourd'hui, il est possible
de consommer différemment du bœuf,
élevé au grand air
et nourri à l'herbe.
Seulement, il faut y mettre le prix.
En moyenne, cette viande
coûte 30 % plus cher
que celle qui sort
des élevages intensifs.
Voilà pourquoi le bœuf industriel,
a conquis la plupart
des assiettes du monde entier.
Face aux problèmes écologiques
que cela pose,
certains ont opté
pour une solution radicale.
À contre-courant
de tout ce qu'il se fait dans le monde,
il y a des endroits, en France,
où l'on a décidé
de manger moins de bœuf qu'avant.
Dans cette école parisienne
par exemple,
tous les mardis, les enfants ont droit
à un repas un peu spécial.
Le plat principal est végétarien.
- Que servez-vous aujourd'hui, mesdames ?
- Des épinards
avec des saucisses de tofu.
- Des saucisses quoi, pardon ?
- Au tofu.
Le tofu, une pâte végétale à base de soja,
qui ce jour-là, apporte les protéines
nécessaires aux enfants.
Une fois par semaine,
il n'y a donc plus de viande
sur le plateau repas.
Pour l'instant,
les jeunes palais ont encore un peu de mal
à s'habituer à ce changement de régime.
- Pas bon.
- Ce n'est pas bon ?
- Ça a un drôle de goût.
- Ça n'a pas le goût de saucisse.
- Ce n'est pas très bon.
- Je pense comme lui.
- Je trouve que c'est bon les repas
végétariens, parfois c'est un peu fade.
- Question goût,
il y a encore du chemin à faire.
Mais manger moins de bœuf
réduit les risques des enfants
d'avoir des maladies cardio-vasculaires.
C'est donc bon pour la santé
et bon pour l'environnement.
Voilà pourquoi ce genre d'initiative
commence à faire école
un peu partout en Europe,
en Angleterre, en Suède ou aux Pays-Bas.
Mais ce mouvement n'en est
qu'à ses débuts.
Car dans l'alimentation,
voici la réalité à laquelle nous sommes
tous confrontés au quotidien.
Nourrir en masse toujours plus de monde,
signifie produire en masse
toujours plus de nourriture.
Une alimentation industrielle
dont on vient de voir
les conséquences
les plus visibles sur l'environnement.
Mais avec cette alimentation mondialisée,
il y a un autre coût écologique,
un impact que nous, consommateurs,
sommes parfois très loin d'imaginer.
Pour nous en rendre compte,
nous sommes allés les yeux grands ouverts
dans un lieu qui nous est familier.
Mais avec cette alimentation mondialisée,
il y a un autre coût écologique,
un impact que nous, consommateurs,
sommes parfois très loin d'imaginer.
Pour nous en rendre compte,
nous sommes allés les yeux grands ouverts,
dans un lieu qui nous est familier.
Dans un hypermarché,
lorsque nous faisons nos courses,
nous avons un choix de plus en plus grand.
Trois fois plus de références
qu'il y a dix ans.
La plupart des produits
viennent du monde entier.
Pour arriver jusqu'à nos rayons,
ils ont souvent fait
un très long voyage.
Qui dit kilomètre,
dit souvent pollution.
Nous sommes allés faire nos courses
avec Élisabeth Laville,
experte en développement durable.
Premier arrêt,
au rayon fruits et légumes.
À force de le consommer toute l'année,
on en oublierait presque que l'ananas,
c'est un fruit qui ne pousse qu'à
des milliers de kilomètres de chez nous.
- Celui-là, par exemple,
est importé par avion.
C'est marqué en petit,
mais c'est marqué dessus.
- Quel est problème ?
- Le problème c'est que l'avion
a un impact considérable,
10 à 20 fois plus d'impact
que le même produit, produit localement,
ce qui là, n'est pas possible.
- Quant aux produits qui poussent
dans nos campagnes,
mauvaise surprise, ce n'est pas forcément
mieux pour l'environnement.
Il faut avoir l'œil sur les étiquettes.
- Même en saison, l'essentiel
de ce qu'on trouve va venir,
les girolles des États-Unis,
la trompette de la mort de Turquie,
le pied de mouton de Bulgarie.
Tiens, il nous en reste
quelques-uns de France
Au rayon conserves,
c'est encore pire,
car la mention de la provenance
n'est pas obligatoire.
Des sardines conditionnées au Maroc,
mais rien ne dit que ce sont les seuls
kilomètres contenues dans cette boîte.
- D'où viennent la boîte,
les sardines, l'huile, etc.,
ce n'est pas indiqué.
Si vous vouliez faire attention à ça,
ce n'est pas évident.
- Très vite, les kilomètres
s'accumulent dans le caddie.
Ananas, cœurs de salade,
poivrons, courgettes,
pommes de terre, champignons,
sardines, espadons, avocats et crevettes.
Avec 10 produits seulement,
le chariot affiche un total
de 45 500 kilomètres au compteur.
Un tour complet de la planète et cela
représente un énorme impact écologique.
- L'alimentation est la première source
d'impact écologique nos vies.
- C'est-à-dire ?
- Ce que vous consommez,
tout ce que vous mangez tous les jours,
a plus d'impact
sur la planète que votre maison,
qu'il faut chauffer, éclairer.
Ou que vos transports, même quand
vous prenez l'avion, la voiture.
- L'alimentation est plus polluante
potentiellement
que n'importe quel autre domaine
de notre vie quotidienne.
- Exactement.
- D'autant que derrière certains produits
se cachent des allers-retours ahurissants.
Exemple : les langoustines.
Pêchés par
des chalutiers en mer du Nord,
elles sont transportées par bateau
d'Europe jusqu'en Thaïlande,
pour être décortiquées
par une main d'œuvre peu cher.
Ensuite, elles repartent dans l'autre sens
pour arriver dans nos rayons.
Total aller-retour :
20 000 kilomètres.
Pour enrayer cette inflation kilométrique,
certains ont décidé de se mobiliser.
Étonnamment, c'est au pays
du fast-food que ça se passe,
aux États-Unis.
Nous sommes sur la côte ouest,
au bord du Pacifique, à San Francisco,
la ville de toutes les mutations.
Après les révolutions hippies,
gays ou high tech,
aujourd'hui, c'est le green business
qui déferle sur la baie.
Le retour à
la terre en quelque sorte.
Dans une ville où beaucoup font attention
à leur ligne et à leur santé,
l'heure est à la guerre
aux kilomètres dans l'assiette.
Et le combat commence ici,
sur le marché fermier du Ferry Plazza,
devenu aussi prisé
que le Golden Gate ou Alcatraz.
Chaque semaine, c'est là que se retrouvent
ceux que l'on appelle les locavores.
Rien à voir avec l'esprit babacool
des années 60.
Ici, être locavore,
c'est très tendance.
- C'est important pour l'environnement,
la santé et pour le goût.
- En achetant des produits du coin, vous
savez que vous soutenez le commerce local.
- C'est un mouvement très important
dans la baie de San Francisco
et on est tous
sur la même longueur d'ondes.
- Le mouvement est né en 2001.
Un écologiste américain
décide alors de mener une expérience,
ne manger que
ce qui pousse autour de chez lui.
Son récit devient un best-seller dans tout
le pays et lance la mode des locavores.
Le principe est le suivant,
ne manger que des produits qui ont voyagé
moins de 150 miles, soit 240 kilomètres.
Les produits de ce stand, par exemple,
viennent d'un ranch à 150 km d'ici.
Ces prunes ont poussé dans un village
à 190 kilomètres de San Francisco.
Ici, tout est produit en Californie.
Donc, pas de café, pas de mangue,
pas de camembert de Normandie.
Malgré cela, le marché fait le plein
toutes les semaines,
et ce succès suscite des vocations.
C'est le cas par exemple
d'un jeune Français, Benoît,
débarqué ici il y a six ans
pour tenter l'aventure
du local business, en Californie.
À la base, une idée simple,
que lui a soufflée sa femme américaine
un yaourt à l'ancienne fait
avec des ingrédients 100 % locaux.
- On en a la fraise,
à la myrtille, au citron.
- Le miel et tous les fruits
de ces yaourts,
c'est ici,
sans autre transport additionnel,
que Benoit les récupère
en main propre chaque semaine.
En quelques années,
son yaourt s'est fait un nom
et son stand ne désemplit pas.
- C'est le côté local,
bio, le packaging
et comme on dit,
la french touch.
C'est un ferment français,
c'est un yaourt un petit peu plus doux,
ça différencie le produit.
- D'ici la fin de la journée,
Benoit aura vendu 500 yaourts.
La demande de produits fabriqués
dans la région, ne cesse d'augmenter.
Actuellement en Californie,
le modèle local est en plein essor.
La plupart des grandes surfaces
se sont lancées sur le créneau,
mais il y en a une
qui surpasse toutes les autres.
Whole Foods, une chaîne d'hypermarchés
bio créée dans les années 80.
C'est là que Benoît écoule
près de la moitié de sa production.
120 points de vente
dans le nord de la Californie.
Désormais, le St. Benoît
est en tête de gondole,
avec en prime
la photo du producteur souriant, naturel
et bien entendu local.
Mais des fabricants comme Benoît,
ça ne se trouve pas si facilement.
Pour s'approvisionner,
l'enseigne doit sans cesse traquer
les meilleurs producteurs de la région.
Pour cela, elle envoie sur le terrain
des têtes chercheuses comme Arve.
Ce prospecteur passe son temps
à quadriller le nord de la Californie,
650 kilomètres en moyenne chaque semaine.
Ce jour-là, Arve a rendez-vous
avec un éleveur de la région
qui produit des œufs
et qui l'intéresse énormément.
Pour l'instant,
il n'a pas de fournisseur
à moins de 2 600 kilomètres d'ici.
- Il y a une grosse demande pour les œufs
de poules élevées en plein air.
Je pense qu'il peut vraiment devenir
un gros fournisseur
pour les magasins du nord de la baie.
Je vais le rencontrer,
voir quel est le potentiel de sa ferme
et si l'on peut travailler ensemble.
Des œufs frais à seulement 50 kilomètres
de San Francisco.
Voilà ce qu'Arve espère trouver ici,
dans la ferme de Don.
- Salut Dawn.
Je suis content de te connaître.
- Moi aussi, salut !
Don est la quatrième génération
de fermier de sa famille.
Un début de carrière dans l'immobilier,
puis à 28 ans,
il a repris l'exploitation familiale
à la retraite de ses parents.
C'était il y a neuf ans.
Outre l'élevage de moutons,
il vient de relancer
la production de poules,
que pratiquaient ses aïeuls,
photos d'époque à l'appui.
- Regardez-moi, ça.
C'est une photo de mon père,
mon oncle et mon grand-père.
Il y a environ 65 ans.
À l'époque,
il élevait des poules ici.
Don compte beaucoup sur cette visite.
Mais avant de faire affaire,
le représentant de Whole Foods,
veut inspecter
l'exploitation de fond en comble.
- Tu les fais tourner tes poules,
de temps en temps,
tu les changes de pâturage ?
- Oui, je viens juste de le faire,
d'ailleurs.
- Les poules sont élevées en liberté,
mais cela ne suffit pas, selon Arve.
- Le bec de tes poules,
il a été coupé.
- Mauvaise nouvelle.
Il ne veut pas de poules
avec des becs coupés.
Selon lui, c'est généralement le signe
des poules élevées en batterie.
Qu'à cela ne tienne,
Don s'adaptera.
- Je peux commander des poules
sans bec coupé, sans problème.
- Ok, pas de bec coupé.
- Un bec pour picorer, une bonne aération,
une alimentation bio.
Le cahier des charges est plutôt lourd
à remplir pour ce jeune agriculteur.
Mais si Don se plie aussi docilement
à toutes les conditions de Whole Foods,
c'est parce qu'il y a
un gros marché à la clé.
120 magasins
dans toute la Californie du Nord,
où vivent 10 millions de personnes,
c'est-à-dire 10 millions
de consommateurs potentiels.
- Je veux juste agrandir parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de demande en ce moment.
- Mais cette demande est nouvelle.
- L'argent, chéri !
Ce type doit nourrir sa famille.
Il doit se nourrir lui-même.
Et il doit faire honneur à son héritage.
- Moi j'espère bien me développer
et Arve va m'aider.
- Donc marché conclu ?
- Marché conclu.
- Cet accord,
pour Don, c'est une aubaine.
D'ici quelques semaines,
il pourra fournir à Arve,
chaque semaine,
200 douzaines d'œufs.
L'enseigne les vendra ensuite
8 $ la douzaine.
C'est deux fois plus cher
que des œufs industriels.
Mais cette formule, peut-elle marcher
partout dans le monde
aussi bien qu'à San Francisco ?
Peut-on être locavore
n'importe où en France,
là où tout ne pousse pas aussi facilement
que dans cette baie miraculeuse ?
Pour le savoir, direction
le bassin parisien,
à la rencontre des locavores français.
Nous sommes à Fontenay-sous-Bois,
loin de San Francisco
et des millions de dollars
que génère le local food.
Ici, l'économie locale, c'est lui.
Jean-Luc Moreau,
agriculteur dans la Marne.
Toutes les semaines, il livre en personne
les 500 kilos de légumes
qu'il a récolté le matin
sur son exploitation,
pour ravitailler
les locavores de Fontenay.
- J'arrive de Broussy-le-Grand,
dans la Marne.
- J'amène mes légumes
pour l'AMAP de Fontenay.
- L'AMAP, ce n'est pas un marché.
C'est l'association pour le maintien
d'une agriculture paysanne.
Un groupement de consommateurs,
comme il y en a 1 200 en France.
Ce jour-là, dans son camion,
des brocolis, des épinards
et une petite originalité de saison.
- Cette semaine, la nouveauté,
ça va être le potimarron.
Car on approche d'Halloween,
puis la courge traditionnellement
arrive à l'automne.
Les gens apprécient la diversité,
la diversification dans le panier,
donc le potimarron.
C'est intéressant
de l'amener maintenant.
- Ces potimarrons
et tous les autres légumes,
les adhérents
les ont achetés en début d'année,
lorsqu'ils ont réglé leur cotisation,
19 € par mois.
- Bonjour, ça va ?
- Ça va, et toi ?
Ce sont les adhérents également
qui assurent la distribution des légumes.
- On a 60 paniers.
- D'accord.
- 60 petits paniers, 48 grands.
- On est loin des linéaires
de Whole Foods en Californie.
Car en France, le modèle locavore
n'en est qu'au stade associatif.
Sébastien, par exemple,
est adhérent de l' AMAP de Fontenay
depuis le tout début, il y a deux ans.
Comme lui, ils sont une centaine
à venir tous les jeudis soirs
récupérer leur panier
sans savoir à l'avance
ce qu'ils vont y trouver.
- C'est une petite surprise à chaque fois.
On est parfois un peu circonspect
en se demandant ce qu'on va en faire.
- Quoi par exemple ?
- Le maïs, on n'a pas l'habitude
d'en cuisiner,
on se demande comment on va le faire.
- La semaine passée, par exemple,
on avait du rutabaga.
C'est un légume que l'on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude de cuisiner,
donc cela nous a permis
de découvrir ce légume.
- Le panier va devoir nourri
toute la famille pendant une semaine.
Sébastien, Mia, Vera, et Théodore.
Livraison suivante, jeudi prochain.
En attendant,
il faudra faire avec ça.
- Des épinards.
C'est quoi ça, Théodore ?
- Non, ce n'est pas ça.
- C'est une grosse courgette, énorme.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est, ça ?
- Le marron !
- C'est un potimarron, oui, c'est vrai.
- Le gros avantage, c'est que les produits
de l'AMAP n'ont pas voyagé.
Comme ces tomates auxquelles
la famille locavore
va faire un sort au dîner.
- Des steaks de tomate.
- Rien à voir donc, avec la plupart
des légumes de supermarché.
- Elles sont cueillies du jour quasiment,
vous voyez la différence.
Elles n'ont pas subi de congélation,
en tout cas de conservation.
Elles ont été cueillies juste à maturité.
Ça fait pas mal de différences.
- Sur la table ce soir,
crudités et purée de pommes de terre
de l'AMAP et cabillaud du marché.
Des menus frais, des légumes de saison,
mais une fois l'hiver venu,
les repas deviennent un peu monotone.
- Il faut manger du chou.
Il faut manger du chou-fleur,
des betteraves.
L'année dernière,
on a eu une overdose de betterave.
Au bout d'un moment, ça lasse.
Il y a eu du radis aussi,
on a eu une overdose de radis.
On n'a pas le choix dans les légumes,
on prend ce que l'on nous donne.
- Malgré ces petits inconvénients,
la version française
des locavores fait ses preuves.
Déjà 60 000 familles adeptes, en France.
Au-delà des produits frais,
peut-on faire le reste de ses courses
en prenant en compte l'environnement ?
Au quotidien, la plupart des Français
s'approvisionnent dans les supermarchés.
Leurs critères de choix :
le prix, la qualité, le goût.
Et depuis peu, la planète.
Avec cet indicateur vert,
l'indice carbone.
C'est Casino,
le premier qui l'a mis en place.
Un indicateur qui mesure
la quantité de gaz carbonique,
c'est-à-dire de gaz à effet de serre,
émis lors de la fabrication des produits.
Prenez, par exemple,
ce paquet de brioche.
Sur l'étiquette,
on peut lire 315 grammes de CO2.
Pour ce paquet de fromage râpé,
l'indice grimpe à 1 190 grammes
de gaz carbonique.
Mais alors, comment
calcule-t-on un indice carbone ?
Pour le mesurer,
un cabinet indépendant
additionne chaque émission de CO2,
de la fabrication
à la distribution d'un produit.
Exemple avec cette plaquette
de chocolat noir.
Pour 100 grammes de produit,
la culture du cacao en Afrique
et de la betterave à sucre en Europe,
auront émis 47 grammes de gaz carbonique.
Le transport des matières premières
jusqu'à l'usine, 41 grammes.
La fabrication de la plaquette,
la phase la moins polluante, 17 grammes.
Les différents emballages, 36 grammes.
Enfin la phase la plus polluante,
l'acheminement de la plaquette de l'usine
jusqu'aux magasins, 179 grammes.
Total, 320 grammes de carbone
émis pour une tablette,
l'équivalent de deux kilomètres en 4x4.
Aujourd'hui, pour certains hypermarchés,
tout l'enjeu est donc de faire baisser
l'impact carbone de leurs produits.
Nous partons pour le centre de la France,
dans la région lyonnaise.
C'est ici que se trouve
le fabricant de chocolats
vendus sous la marque Casino.
Ce jour-là, le distributeur a envoyé
dans l'usine, Corinne Mercadier,
la spécialiste de l'indice carbone
de l'enseigne.
Sa mission, pousser son fournisseur
à être plus écologique
dans sa façon
de produire du chocolat.
Mais pour y arriver,
elle va devoir se montrer convaincante
auprès du fabricant.
- On est dans la zone
de conditionnement des produits.
Où on va emballer les tablettes.
- Corinne Mercadier a listé une dizaine
de points à améliorer.
Comme la question de la distance
parcourue par les matières premières.
Exemple : le sucre.
- J'ai regardé
au niveau des kilomètres,
vous avez trois fournisseurs d'ingrédients
pour le sucre à base de betterave.
Serait-il possible
de travailler majoritairement
avec celui qui est plus proche
de chez vous ?
- Trop risqué, selon le fabricant.
- Le sucre est une matière
sensible chez nous
car c'est un des ingrédients
principaux du chocolat.
On est obligés de s'approvisionner
chez différents fournisseurs
pour être sûr de ne pas avoir
de rupture de stock.
- Pas de sucre, pas de chocolat.
L'argument est imparable.
Pas question de mettre en péril
la production, même pour la planète.
Qu'à cela ne tienne,
Corinne Mercadier suggère
d'autres pistes à explorer.
Utiliser par exemple du papier recyclé
pour emballer le chocolat.
Imprimer directement le code-barres
sur l'étui pour économiser des étiquettes
ou encore diminuer l'épaisseur
d'un carton pour en consommer moins.
Le fournisseur veut bien tout étudier
à une condition, une seule,
que ça ne lui coûte pas plus cher.
- Seriez-vous tentés
d'augmenter le prix du produit ?
- C'est la problématique,
si les améliorations environnementales
provoquent des augmentations de coûts,
il est possible qu'on ne soit
plus forcément concurrentiels
par rapport à d'autres
fournisseurs de chocolats.
Voilà donc la difficulté
d'intégrer la dimension écologique
quand on fait du chocolat.
Mais le fabricant va devoir s'y plier,
car la grande enseigne va de plus en plus
prendre en compte l'environnement
dans le choix de ses fournisseurs.
- Si je suis un fabricant de chocolat
comme eux, même qualité de produit
et eux travaillent sur l'environnement
et pas moi.
- Il aura plus de chances.
- On commanderait
davantage leurs produits.
- À mon niveau, je vais travailler
de façon privilégiée
avec le fournisseur qui fait des efforts.
- Comme ce fabricant de chocolat,
des industriels commencent
à faire des efforts.
Et des produits à faible impact
environnemental apparaissent peu à peu,
Mais encore très peu de consommateurs
ont la possibilité de les acheter.
À l'échelle du globe,
cela reste même une infime minorité.
Pour la plus grande partie
de la population mondiale,
l'enjeu alimentaire est tout autre.
Nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux sur Terre
et la planète, elle,
arrive de moins en moins à fournir.
Dans certains pays,
cela a même pris
une dimension tragique,
une pénurie qui provoque
parfois violence et révolte.
Printemps 2008, le monde découvre
des émeutes sans précédent.
Sénégal, Haïti, Vietnam, Egypte,
ils sont des centaines de milliers
à descendre dans la rue car ils ont faim.
Des émeutes qui seront
réprimées dans le sang.
Pour faire face
à cette pénurie alimentaire,
certains pays ont trouvé la solution.
Partir à des milliers de kilomètres
de chez eux,
à la conquête d'espaces vierges
pour les cultiver.
Dans le monde, se joue actuellement
une gigantesque partie de Monopoly.
Principaux joueurs, les Chinois,
les Indiens ou les Saoudiens
qui manquent de terres cultivables.
Leur cible, des pays pauvres
qui proposent de leur louer des terrains.
Il y en a partout, en Asie,
mais aussi à l'autre bout du globe,
en Amérique latine.
Et surtout en Afrique.
Un pays y attire
en ce moment toutes les convoitises.
C'est l'Éthiopie.
Cela peut sembler paradoxal
car pour la plupart d'entre nous,
l'Éthiopie, ça évoque d'abord ça.
We are the World,
une chanson destinée, en 1985,
à récolter des dons pour l'Éthiopie.
Avec ce tube,
le monde entier découvre alors
un pays en train de mourir de faim.
La famine fait un million de morts,
dont des centaines de milliers d'enfants.
Les images de l'époque
montrent des paysages désertiques,
des terres sèches et arides.
Mais l'Éthiopie offre aussi
un autre visage totalement inattendu.
Vue du ciel,
on dirait la Beauce.
Des millions d'hectares
de terres vertes et fertiles,
cultivées de manière archaïque
par la population.
Voilà ce qui attire les étrangers.
Et pour découvrir comment ils investissent
et exploitent ces terres,
nous nous dirigeons
vers l'Ouest, dans l'Oromia,
une des régions agricoles du pays.
Bako, une petite ville
située à 2300 m d'altitude.
C'est ici que se trouve l'un des plus gros
investisseurs étrangers du pays.
Karuturi, une entreprise indienne.
Il est 6 h du matin.
Nous avons rendez-vous
avec un homme qui s'appelle Razak.
Un des managers de la ferme.
Bonjour, est-ce que Monsieur Razak est là,
s'il vous plaît ?
[English spoken audio]
Razak est arrivé d'Inde,
en avril dernier.
Comme lui, une douzaine d'employés indiens
vivent dans cette ferme.
Ici, on a du mal à croire
qu'on est en Éthiopie.
Même le petit déjeuner n'a rien de local.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Du curry à 6 h 30 du matin ?
- Au menu, du curry
de pommes de terre, très épicé.
- Ça réveille !
À 5 000 kilomètres de chez lui,
Razak a le mal du pays.
Les chaînes de télé indiennes permettent
de garder un contact avec l'Inde.
Là-bas, il a dû laisser femme et enfants.
Il ne les voit que
pour les grandes vacances.
- Ça, c'est votre chambre ?
- Dans sa chambre,
il garde précieusement un album photo.
Un réconfort dans
les moments difficiles.
- C'est votre femme et vos deux enfants ?
- Oui.
- J'imagine qu'ils vous manquent.
- Oui, mais ils m'appellent
tous les matins.
- Depuis quand
vous ne les avez pas vus ?
- Depuis juillet.
La prochaine fois c'est en mai.
- Vous ne les aurez pas vus
pendant presque un an !
- Oui, mais c'est mieux
pour l'éducation des enfants.
Si Razak est prêt
à de tels sacrifices,
c'est qu'un riche propriétaire indien
lui a confié une mission importante.
Faire pousser en Ethiopie du maïs,
du riz et des légumes.
Pour se rendre sur ses terres,
c'est tout un périple.
Razak doit faire 1 h de tracteur.
Cette route de fortune,
c'est son entreprise qui l'a construite
en plein milieu des champs.
Son terrain est tellement grand,
qu'il lui faut toute la technologie
moderne pour se repérer.
- Vous utilisez un GPS
pour vous repérer ?
- Oui, vous voyez,
c'est là qu'on est, exactement ici.
En Inde, le deuxième pays
le plus peuplé au monde,
le patron de Razak
ne trouvait pas de terres disponibles.
Alors, c'est en Éthiopie qu'il a tenté
sa chance et il a gagné le gros lot.
- Tout ça est à vous ?
11 000 hectares,
une surface gigantesque.
- Toutes ces terres au nord,
elles sont à nous.
Sur ces terres, Razak prévoit
de planter des céréales et des légumes.
La majorité de la production
sera exportée vers l'Inde et l'Asie.
- Combien vous avez acheté ces terres ?
- On les loue au gouvernement éthiopien.
C'est un bail très long.
- Combien de temps ?
- Aux alentours de 60 ans.
- 60 ans ! C'est beaucoup.
- Oui, c'est beaucoup.
Mais pour développer tout ça,
il faut du temps.
On ne peut pas réussir en cinq ans.
- Combien ça coûte ici, le loyer ?
- Je ne peux pas trop vous répondre.
Il faut poser
la question au patron.
- C'est un peu compliqué ?
- Non, ce n'est pas compliqué.
- Razak est un peu gêné par la question.
Il faut dire que le loyer est dérisoire.
3 € par an et par hectare, une des terres
les moins chères de la planète.
Voilà donc ce qui incite beaucoup
d'étrangers à venir planter dans ce pays.
Maïs saoudien,
vignes françaises, fraises israéliennes.
On vient du monde entier
pour profiter des promotions éthiopiennes.
Cela tombe bien, l'État qui est
propriétaire des terres, est généreux.
D'ici cinq ans, il va distribuer
2 millions d'hectares aux investisseurs.
Sur ses terres,
Razak, lui, a décidé de miser sur l'une
des céréales les plus cultivées en Inde,
mais aussi l'une des plus rentables.
- Alors, il est comment ce riz ?
- Ça va être une bonne récolte.
- C'est à l'intérieur
de ces grande herbes vertes,
que mûrissent les grains de riz.
Une céréale très demandée
qui constitue la base de l'alimentation
de la moitié de l'humanité.
À terme, la ferme indienne compte produire
5 millions de tonnes de riz en Éthiopie.
Destination l'Inde, le reste de l'Asie
et même l'Europe.
- La demande
de nourriture va exploser.
Il n'y a pas assez
de terres disponibles
et on a besoin de plus en plus
de nourriture pour vivre.
Avec un tel marché,
notre projet va être énorme.
Je pense que d'ici quelques années,
nous serons sinon le plus grand,
en tout cas l'un des plus grands groupes
agro-alimentaires du monde.
- L'entreprise indienne vient d'ailleurs
d'obtenir du gouvernement
300 000 hectares supplémentaires.
Pour cultiver des surfaces aussi grandes,
les Indiens se sont équipés
une trentaine de tracteurs,
directement importés des États-Unis.
Tout reste à faire.
La plupart des terres
sont encore complètement vierges.
Razak, s'est donné six mois
pour tout planter.
Près des pelleteuses,
les villageois continuent à faire paître
leur bétail comme depuis toujours.
Mais bientôt,
ils vont devoir partir.
- On tolère les villageois,
car ici on ne cultive pas encore.
Mais c'est la dernière saison.
- C'est la dernière saison pour eux.
- Oui.
On leur a demandé de partir après.
Razak n'a pas d'états d'âme,
c'est la règle du jeu en Éthiopie.
Quand les investisseurs
étrangers s'installent,
les paysans doivent souvent
leur céder la place.
Pour nous rendre compte
du bouleversement,
direction Bachara,
un village proche de la plantation.
Ici, depuis l'arrivée des Indiens,
certains paysans ont été expulsés.
C'est le cas de Tafari,
ce jeune fermier.
Il n'a que 18 ans
mais déjà deux enfants.
Derrière sa maison,
il nous conduit un petit lopin de terre
où il fait pousser du maïs
- Tout ça, c'est à vous ?
Un demi hectare,
c'est tout ce qu'il lui reste.
20 fois moins
que ce qu'il cultivait avant.
- Ça vous suffit pour vivre ?
- Non, je travaille dur,
mais ce n'est pas assez
pour nourrir ma famille.
Je vais devoir vendre deux vaches
pour acheter de la nourriture
et essayer de tenir.
Quand il avait ses terres, Tafari
vendait ses récoltes sur le marché
et vivait beaucoup mieux.
Mais depuis six mois,
à la place de son ancien champ,
il y a ce grand bâtiment.
C'est la plantation des Indiens.
- Là-bas, c'était mon terrain.
J'avais 10 hectares.
Je cultivais du tef et du sésame.
- Que s'est-il passé ?
Pourquoi vous avez perdu votre terre ?
- Le gouvernement nous interdit
de cultiver ici.
On nous dit que ça appartient
aux Indiens maintenant.
Comme lui, une centaine de villageois
cultivait ses terres
depuis des générations.
Pour les expulser,
le gouvernement a trouvé un prétexte,
un impôt qu'il ne leur avait jamais
réclamé auparavant.
- Les autorités sont venus nous voir
et ils nous ont dit mot pour mot :
Vous ne payez pas de taxes,
donc ce n'est plus votre terrain
maintenant, c'est celui
des investisseurs étrangers.
Nous, on leur a proposé
de payer les taxes,
mais ils nous ont dit non,
c'est trop tard.
Soudain, l'interview
prend une autre tournure.
Derrière nous s'approche
un homme armé d'une kalachnikov.
Il fait partie du service d'ordre
de la ferme indienne.
- Mais pourquoi avez-vous une arme ?
On protège les Indiens.
Des villageois les ont menacés
avec des cailloux et des machettes.
Très vite, un attroupement
se forme face à face.
Ceux qui ont accepté
de travailler avec les Indiens
et ceux qui ont perdu
leurs terres à cause d'eux.
Tous habitent
pourtant le même village.
- Vous seriez prêt à tuer quelqu'un
de votre propre communauté ?
- Non. Mais si quelqu'un s'approche,
je tirerai en l'air.
On le capturera
et il ira en prison.
Entre les deux camps,
le ton monte.
- Pourquoi tu travailles pour eux ?
Ils payent bien au moins ?
Non, je ne gagne pas beaucoup,
mais je n'ai pas le choix.
Il n'y a pas
de travail dans la région.
Est-ce que ça a
vraiment amélioré ta vie ?
- Très peu.
J'ai des enfants à nourrir, moi.
Mieux vaut avoir un petit travail
que rien du tout.
L'emploi, un argument repris
par tous ceux qui défendent
l'implantation des étrangers.
En Éthiopie,
deux personnes sur trois sont au chômage.
Alors devant les fermes,
dans les villages,
nous sommes toujours témoins
de la même scène.
Des centaines d'hommes et de femmes
venus des campagnes alentour
espérant être embauchés pour la journée.
Certains attendent ici plusieurs jours
sans manger.
On n'a pas de travail,
on n'a pas d'argent.
On a faim,
nous, personne ne nous embauche.
On veut travailler pour les étrangers,
ne plus être chômeurs.
C'est une bonne chose qu'ils viennent,
on aura du travail
et on gagnera notre vie.
Justement
sur la plantation des Indiens, Razak
lui, donne du travail.
300 personnes employées actuellement,
1200 lors des prochaines récoltes.
La plupart n'a aucune qualification.
Il est trop court.
Il faut que ça fasse au moins
12 ou 13 centimètres.
Mais l'avantage pour Razak,
c'est que cette main d'œuvre non qualifiée
est très bon marché,
jusqu'à 50 % moins cher qu'en Inde.
Dousha, par exemple,
elle a quinze ans.
Elle a arrêté l'école
pour aider sa famille.
8 h par jour, elle enlève les mauvaises
herbes autour des plantations.
Elle gagne
l'équivalent de 11 € par mois.
Selon elle, c'est très peu,
même en Éthiopie.
- Je pourrais gagner
plus d'argent ailleurs.
J'ai travaillé dans une autre ferme
qui me payait plus
pour faire exactement le même travail.
- Pourquoi vous restez là
et vous ne travaillez pas ailleurs ?
Cette autre ferme était loin
et je devais beaucoup marcher.
Celle-ci est près de ma maison.
J'aime travailler ici,
mais je voudrais être payée plus.
Razak, elle dit qu'elle aime son job,
mais que vous ne la payez pas assez.
Personne n'est jamais
content de son salaire.
Tout le monde veut plus.
Ici, ce n'est pas la saison.
Il n'y a pas de travail nulle part.
Nous, on en donne.
Si elle était domestique,
elle gagnerait plus d'argent, c'est sûr.
Mais qui va lui donner du travail ici ?
Les villageois ?
Faute de mieux,
Dousha reste travailler chez les Indiens.
Un emploi qui pour l'instant
ne change pas grand chose
à ses conditions de vie.
La jeune fille habite à 1 h
à pied de la plantation
dans une maison traditionnelle.
La vache, seul bien de la famille,
trône dans le salon.
Au total, ils sont neuf à vivre ici.
Le comble c'est que pour le repas du soir,
Dousha prépare des légumes
qui ne viennent pas
de la plantation où elle travaille.
On est employé par les indiens
mais on ne mange pas ce qu'on cultive.
Parce que ce n'est pas vendu en Éthiopie.
De toute façon, ce serait trop cher
vu ce que je gagne.
Et c'est là le paradoxe.
L'Etat donne toujours plus d'hectares
aux étrangers,
mais n'exige pas que les employés
éthiopiens soient mieux payés.
Résultat, beaucoup
ne parviennent pas à vivre.
25 ans après la grande famine,
plus de 5 millions de personnes
ne subsistent encore
que grâce à l'aide alimentaire.
L'Éthiopie vient même
de demander en urgence
80 millions d'euros
à la communauté internationale.
Mais alors,
pourquoi brader des terres aux étrangers
si on n'arrive pas
à nourrir suffisamment son peuple ?
Pour trouver une réponse,
nous nous rendons à Addis Abeba,
la capitale, le siège du pouvoir.
Officiellement,
le pays est aujourd'hui une démocratie.
Officiellement seulement, car en réalité,
il s'agit d'un régime autoritaire,
l'un des plus sévères d'Afrique.
Nous avons rendez-vous
avec le ministre de l'agriculture,
Tafara Derbio.
- Bonjour ! Merci de nous recevoir,
Monsieur le ministre.
C'est lui qui attribue
les terres aux étrangers.
D'un côté, vous avez plus de 5 millions
de personnes qui dépendent
de l'aide alimentaire et de l'autre,
vous brader vos terres
aux investisseurs étrangers.
Pourquoi vous faites ça ?
Justement, on va moins dépendre
de l'aide alimentaire grâce aux étrangers.
Grâce à ces fermes, des millions
de paysans vont s'en sortir.
Cela va améliorer
la qualité de vie des gens.
Notre seule richesse,
ce sont nos terres.
On fait quoi ?
On attend que nos paysans
développent ses terres d'ici 30 à 40 ans ?
Ou on les cultive dès maintenant
grâce aux étrangers.
C'est important que ces terres
soient cultivées le plus vite possible.
Quand on l'interroge sur les paysans
expulsés sans aucune indemnisation,
voici ce qu'il répond :
On vous a mal renseigné.
Vous êtes allé voir quelques
fermiers qui se plaignent,
qui sont paresseux
et qui ne travaillent pas assez.
C'est peut être pour cela
qu'on leur donne rien
parce qu'ils sont inefficaces.
Donc les paysans qui se plaignent
sont feignants.
- Oui.
J'ai rencontré
des paysans éthiopiens
qui ne sont pas feignants
et qui gagnent la plupart du temps
11 € par mois
et qui n'arrivent pas à vivre avec.
Ma question, sans vous manquer de respect,
est la suivante :
ne pensez vous pas que vous laissez
les étrangers exploiter votre peuple ?
Non, on ne laisse pas
notre peuple se faire exploiter.
On essaye de créer des emplois.
Vous ne voulez pas imposer
un salaire minimum
comme c'est le cas
dans la plupart des pays du monde ?
Laissons le marché décider
le prix de la main d'œuvre.
Avec cette politique volontariste,
l'Éthiopie espère devancer ses voisins
et devenir le pays africain
le plus populaire
auprès des investisseurs.
C'est sur ces terres éthiopiennes
que s'achève notre voyage.
Un voyage à la découverte
d'une alimentation mondialisée.
À l'échelle planétaire,
nourrir chacun d'entre nous
est donc un défi
qui soulève des questions
bien plus complexes
que nous ne l'imaginions.
Pourtant, dès maintenant,
le citoyen peut agir souvent
grâce à quelques règles de bon sens.
Comme par exemple
privilégier les produits de saison
et les aliments bio.
Certaines initiatives
aujourd'hui marginales,
devraient se banaliser
et offrir au consommateur
de vraies alternatives.
Comme Casino,
la plupart des grandes enseignes
prévoient d'afficher
l'impact environnemental
sur leurs produits d'ici 2012.
Findus a banni l'huile de palme
de ces produits.
D'autres grandes marques
cherchent aussi
des huiles meilleures pour la santé
et l'environnement.
Des cantines suppriment la viande
une fois par semaine,
d'autres se mettent au bio
sous la pression des parents.
Cela concernera une école sur quatre
d'ici trois ans.
Les locavores comptent de plus
en plus d'adeptes en France.
Ils sont 15 % de plus cette année
à préférer des légumes
et des fruits de saison
produits à proximité de chez eux.
Selon les Nations Unies,
si nous appliquions
ce type de solution très concrète,
la Terre aurait la capacité
de nourrir 12 milliards d'individus,
presque le double de ce
que compte aujourd'hui l'humanité.